Oh Trump is calling Democrats the party
of Maxine Waters the president attacked
the Democratic congresswoman yesterday
after she encouraged people to make a
scene if they see Trump cabinet members
in public CBS Evening News anchor Jeff
Glor spoke with a group of voters in
California to discuss the increasingly
heated rhetoric in our politics which of
course said that he spoke with three
conservatives Dorothy Kistler Brook
Bower and Floyd Johnson the second two
liberals
Sydney Lee res and hema day and one
independent Willie Murray
they told Jeff how our divisive
political climate is making people act
meaner it seems like there's less
civility right now yeah all the way
around
there's no it's appalling it's
absolutely appalling I'm very upset with
the hate that is going on and in
particular people who work for the
government and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
you know being led out of the restaurant
and not serve because of who she works
for
I don't think that's right if it was my
restaurant I wouldn't serve that person
oh you wouldn't you wouldn't serve I've
seen Miss Huckabee do her press
conferences and the way she talked to
some of those reporters is like totally
disrespectful so when you go out you go
you're gonna feel that you're gonna get
somebody is gonna say something to you
because you've offended the people that
are watching you you know I think it's
just indicative of really a larger
problem with with our discourse we've
got when I watch the news for example I
feel like I'm told every day that I'm a
racist I'm a bigot I'm a homophobe
because I just believe in slightly
different things I think at the end of
the day really all of us want the same
thing I just disagree on execution and I
think that when we're seeing all the
things with Sarah how could be Sanders
being kicked out of a restaurant what
Maxine Waters is saying we're all
looking at each other
as members of parties rather than as
human beings let me go around the table
quickly would you ask her to leave no
nope no no nope I wouldn't ask her to
leave either I just think that you know
you're going down a slippery slope if
you start saying I'm not gonna serve you
because I disagree with who you are who
you work for I think it's very dangerous
you can see more from John herbivore
like crickets okay you can see more from
Jeff Glor panel on the CBS Evening News
tonight how these voters feel about
President Trump's immigration policy